Aaron Rodgers finally weighs in on his
Bachelorette star brother the Green Bay
Packers quarterbacks name is all over
the bachelorettes this season his
younger brother Jordan is in the final
two and Jordan revealed their family
estrangement to millions of viewers
me and Aaron don't really have that much
of a relationship it's just kind of the
way he's chosen to to do life and
Tuesday WISN in Wisconsin caught up with
Aaron at training camp where he revealed
quote I haven't seen the show to be
honest with you so it hasn't really
affected me a whole lot and Aaron would
not explain his relationship with his
family I've always found that it's a
little inappropriate to talk publicly
about some family matters but I wish him
well in the competition I was with Jo Jo
Fletcher at the Bachelorette men tell
all taping in LA just a few days ago
here's what she had to say about what
pulled the Rogers brothers apart had
something that I feel like I should pry
into um I will say that the stuff that
Jordan told me on that date it was um it
was actually quite sweet how he handled
it erin has seemingly been estranged
from his family including Jordan their
brother Luke and their parents for over
two years he and Jordan were last
photographed together in public in April
2014 and on social media there are no
signs of Aaron spending time with his
family even on holidays